[Musique]
super smash bros voilà une saga
incontournable du jeu vidéo
encore plus depuis l'opus wii u et 3ds
qui ont totalement relancé les ventes de
nintendo
cependant la switch est maintenant sorti
et lounge commencent à mourir à petit
feu et la 3ds aussi dans le futur
beaucoup suspectent l'arrivée d'un
nouveau smash bros sur switch tout comme
il y eut mario kart suites de luxe ou
encore poken dx je suis d'accord avec
ceux ci
je suis même sûr à 95 % d'un futur smash
développer sur switch cependant quel
personnage pourrait-il y avoir sur ce
nouveau smash et bien c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec mes amis y louer nm lt
du studio koke ou d'
ce sont des grands fans de ce match et
c'est vraiment un plaisir de faire cette
vidéo en leur compagnie et je vous
recommande leur chaîne qui tout
simplement génial 100% pokémon c'est
l'une des rares chaînes qui me fait
autant rire
n'hésitez pas allez la tchëque et nous
en reparlerons en fin de vidéo
c'est parti pour les futurs possibles
personnage un prochain smash bros que la
pluie de théories commence et glisse
partout nouvelles licences de nintendo
de par son gameplay son univers coloré
et son côté compétitive a fait naître
une communauté de fans assez importante
aussi il ya de bonnes raisons de penser
que les inkling seront jouables dans un
nouveau smash bros les personnages de ce
match sont souvent là pour représenter
une console particulière une époque où
une licence les ics ligne serait alors
là en tant que représentant de la wiiu
en plus d'essence platoon qui a été un
succès sur une console qui en avait bien
besoin
le jeu possède des aspects un gameplay
qui rendrait assez facile la venue de
certains personnages à rennes et objets
dans smash bros les cycliques sont les
combattants de base en faire des
personnages de smash bros ne demanderait
pas autant d'efforts d'imagination que
pour le villageois pour leur duo duck
hunt par exemple on peut imaginer
nicklin chant gendarmes avec un bouton
comme le dresseur de pokémon qui
appelait le pokémon suivant avec son
débat ou alors plusieurs personnages
inkling chacun avec une anse platines dj
comme par exemple le rouleau le
liquidateur le blaster ou bien on peut
imaginer qu'une arme sera attitré à
chaque coup et que le personnage en
changerait automatiquement tout comme
link alter entre l'arc les paix le boom
rome
par contre une des limites à cette
théorie c'est que je ne vois pas
vraiment comment le système de peinture
pour être transcrit un smash bros sans
paraître abuser l'encours était resté au
sol indéfiniment le fait même de pouvoir
se fondre et se déplacer dans l'antre de
rendre et il pas le personnage
complètement intouchable et donc trop
fort me semble que cette mécanique de ce
plateau qui en est un fondement doit
être adaptée pour obtenir des inkling
équilibrée au casting de smash bros dans
tous les cas et c'est sur mon meilleur
argument si les inkling était jouable
moi j'ai spam riz la provoc h 24 à l'esc
le beurre bon ok je ne prends vraiment
pas beaucoup de risque en pariant sur le
retour de ice climbers initialement il
était prévu pour les opus 3ds et wii ou
pour ceux qui n'étaient pas au courant
leur développement fonctionner
parfaitement bien sur wiiu
au point où seize d'entre eux tourner
correctement en mode smash à 8
le problème est en fait venue
délimitation d'un 3ds qui ne permettait
pas d'affichés huit personnages
fonctionnant à 60 fps multi né manquent
ou par obligation d'avoir le même
contenu personnage dans les deux
versions
ils ont été retirés des deux purement et
simplement ils n'ont donc pas été
véritablement surpris mais par choix
mais plus par contrainte aussi avec la
switch il ne devrait y avoir aucun
problème des limitations techniques pour
pouvoir les réintégrer au casting est
slumbers sont appréciés et ils sont très
loin d'être des clones d'autres
personnages même harmonie et l'humain ne
se joue pas de la même façon
donc oui le retour des spurs c'est un
grand oui nos petits
à parlons d'un des persos que j'aime le
plus dans les jeux vidéo ou noctis
noctis et le personnage principal de
final fantasy 15 le jeu chouchou de
square enix
après dix ans de développement final
fantasy qu'un suite un jeu qui a très
bien marché et qui fut très attendu
korenix pour la rentabilité de ce
dernier n'hésite pas à pousser leurs
bébés au maximum avec de nombreux dlc
sortis sur le long terme et leur
rajouter une version portable puis pc
et de nombreux goodies et j'en passe
final fantasy 15 et le bébé de square
enix
de plus si vous êtes un fan de la
licence vous avez forcément dû le
remarquer mais square enix essaie de
faire son maximum pour que noctis
devienne le personnage célèbre de la
franchise est dépassée cloud ils ont
similairement la même histoire en terme
d' amour par exemple et square enix
essayent de pousser noctis à son maximum
est de permettre aux fans de
s'identifier à lui
noctis va devenir le personnage phare de
la franchise il symbolise l'évolution et
le futur de la série et ressemble à
cloud pour justement mieux l'apprécier
maintenant il faut savoir que square
enix et nintendo sont de très bons
alliés
je ne compte plus le nombre de final
fantasy sur ds ils ont fait de nombreux
partenariats et l'intégration de cloud
dans smash bros le montre bien
nintendo et square enix sont alliés
réfléchissez-y square enix va
certainement demander à ce que notre
offre dans le prochain smash bros pour
toucher les fans de nintendo
cela ne m'étonnerait pas du tout il
pourrait avoir une touche a signé pour
chaque arme et la téléportation dû à son
pouvoir du lui si ce serait sans recover
sur le terrain pour éviter tomber on
peut imaginer ceux ci en tout cas
personnellement j'espère le voir dans le
prochain smash et je suis sûr qu'il y
sera archi plus qu à chaque nouveau
super smash bros le casting pokémon se
renouvelle voyez où je veux en venir je
pense que le prochain opus
rome - un nouveau pokémon dans son
roster mais lequel tout d'abord il faut
avoir en tête que les développeurs de ce
match en plus d'implémenter des pokémon
populaire et c'est également ajouter les
nouvelles mécaniques de jeu pokémon en
effet serez version wii outre les s nous
avons eu droit aux personnages manfoumbi
mais aussi des modifications du phare
images de l'eau cariou aidera conclu
pour mettre en avant la méga évolution
du coup dans le cas d'un nouveau smash
bros serait évident de penser qu'un ou
plusieurs pokémon de la septième
génération serait présent à pokémon
populaire donc et dans l'idéal un qui
possède une capacité z signatures pour
moi archiduc et puis désigné a vu sa
notoriété sa forme humide et appropriée
pour en faire un combattant le smash
bros il serait le seul pokémon de type
planque du groupe et il possède une
attaque et une capacité de signature
aussi penser à fait l'inferno mais après
réflexion il serait sûrement trop proche
dracaufeu un style bourrin courte portée
pour pas ranger les choses les dont le
tube feu c'est pourquoi je pense qu'à
celle du corps et plus de chances de
devenir un personnage jouable malgré le
fait qu'on l'ait déjà link et pitt en
archi le smash bros et pour lequel
oratoriens le troisième du trio son
design est pas adapté à smash bros donc
non la place de cheveux net me paraît
vraiment très légitime le jeu était un
carton et le personnage est complètement
taillis pour combat techniquement même
si je ne sais pas comment il ferait pour
par exemple la taille de récupération le
fameux bo
en dehors de ça il ya une foule de
possibilités avec les différentes
capacités du personnage entre les
pouvoirs magiques des roddick c'est à
dire la baguette à redon aura une boule
de feu les points poussière qui
permettra de donner une grosse patate
dans les dents lancre de lancer qui
touche en hauteur le corps de guerre qui
pourra faire une excellente attaque
d'ultimes ou bien même le fait qu'on
rebondisse sur l'ennemi lorsqu'on
descend pic sur lui en lui assénant un
coup de pelle un peu à la façon d'en
finale bis et bien avec tous ces
éléments on se rend compte qu'en termes
d' attaque il ya quand même beaucoup de
possibilités en plus de ça on peut aussi
s'interroger sur la relation entre
nintendo et yatch club games le studio
derrière cheveux la night avant de
sortir sur plusieurs autres consoles et
en dehors du pc le jeu était au départ
exclusif au support 3ds et wii ou par la
suite il ya un ami beaux cheveux nattés
encore aujourd'hui trois autres animaux
de la licence ont été annoncés et pour
finir il y avait même déjà eu une rumeur
en ou 2015 où il était dit que chevreuil
net pourrait rejoindre le casting de
smash bros
bon ça a été démenti par yatch club
games qui avait répondu qu'il apprécie l
enthousiasme pour cette idée mais que
c'était sans doute une erreur
aujourd'hui je me dis que c'était
peut-être une main tendue et qu'il est
probable que ça se fasse
en tout cas je pense que ça ferait
plaisir à beaucoup de monde surtout
qu'il est vraiment de quoi faire avec le
personnage et l'univers
après il y a juste un truc qui me
dérange c'est que le riz n'est pas une
production japonaise
et ça c'est pas un petit frein
wolf personnages phares de la licence
star fox je me devais de parler de wolf
law rival de fox et leader de stars wolf
wolf faisait partie de super smash bros
brawl et a totalement disparu dans super
smash bros reçu il est vrai que la série
starfox a fortement chuté ces derniers
mois notamment à cause de starbucks 0
sorti sur wii loup en 2016 et cumulant
seulement 400 milles vente sans compter
les nombreuses notes moyennes ou pas
très folichonne super smash bros étant
un jeu de combat avec énormément de fan
service nintendo a privilégié les
licences qui marche comme fire emblem
avec corinne ou reuil par exemple ce qui
est normal et tout à fait honorable
cependant wolf était un personnage très
apprécié des fans et n'était pas un
clown comme lucina avec morse par
exemple son gameplay bien que
ressemblant à celui de falco et fox
avait ses particularités est aujourd'hui
en 2017 starfox deux incontestables des
jeux star fox est revenu sur l'année ce
mini cars ressorti nintendo et devinez
quoi où elle fait partie de cet opus
de quoi encore plus incité à remettre
walf dans le jeu pour un bon coup de pub
pour la nes min après tout wolf a déjà
été intégrée à brawl son développement
sur swiss ne devrait donc pas être très
compliqué wolf était un personnage que
j'aimais beaucoup dans brawl et j'espère
bien le revoir dans le prochain smash
je crois en cette chance
quand on voit le nombre de personnages
jouables dans smash bros wii aux issues
de l'univers mario on se dit qu'il est
temps d'acheter de nouvelles licences et
parmi les petits nouveaux les nintendo
streetg il y a une licence qui pourrait
faire à faire je le parlais des armes
le jeu se prête plutôt bien la castagne
duel façon smash bros étant lui-même un
jeu de combat mais combattants qui
représente le mieux armes selon moi sont
spring mammeri bond girl
ce sont des personnages qui parlent même
à ceux qui n'ont pas joué au jeu et qui
auront juste entendu vaguement parlé
pour les craintes que le personnage
n'est finalement que très peu de co
disponibles et faire comme sony
principalement des taxis mer
pour ma façon de jouer un personnage de
house pourrait être plus riches car les
points en des formes variées et peut
avoir des effets différents thèmes
exposés trop rapides et les attaques et
c'est tout comme mega man qui gagne les
coûts de ses ennemis les points d'un
personnage peuvent être donnés à
d'autres ou encore plus de possibilités
le vrai souci c'est la porté des coups
de poing qui est énorme alors pour le
jeu c'est un problématique au contraire
et dans le cas d'un smash bros qui est
un jeu en 2d c'est assez déséquilibré
alors vous me direz il pouvait y avoir
des ajustements pour que les attaques
soient moins longues simplement
après tout il ya déjà des réglages ce
type pour certains personnages très
proches comme pau dracaufeu qui ne peut
pas voler cependant c'est l'un des
piliers de gm se battre à coups de poing
téléguidé à distance devait rapporter ce
serait passer à côté de ça après une
grande partie des combats réside dans le
fait qu'il faut savoir qu'en lancer ces
points car on est vulnérable aux coups
quand ils sont lancés et qu'ils peuvent
se casser sous le joug des attaques
ennemies
si cet aspect suffisamment bien
retranscrit dans sa future smash bros ça
permettrait de rendre le personnage sans
doute un peu plus équilibré déjà pour
finir je dirais que smash bros permet de
faire la pub aux licences qui sont
dedans
par exemple la popularité le kid icarus
a grandement grimpé avec la présence de
l'opic dans drôles
c'est pourquoi mettre un personnage de
homs dans smash bros augmenterez très
certainement les ventes du jeu arms quoi
de mieux pour une licence qui va être
créée sont pas cons nintendo quoi j'ai
envie de dire non mais à l'eau due aux
alizés des droits généraux
je voulais intégrer le personnage de
chanter dans mon top 3 car selon moi
elle est tout à fait hostile pour
intégrer le casting de smash bros
et en plus bas je la préfère mais ça
c'est le personnage que j'aimerais et
par ses beats lui paraît le plus
probable
du coup j'ai beaucoup hésité pour le
personnage que je vais vous présenter et
finalement je me suis dit que nintendo à
force de puiser dans ses licences les
plus populaires allait bientôt se
retrouver sans rien et qu'à un moment
donné il faudra bien un peu de sang neuf
et voilà donc chibi robo un petit robot
ménager avec un design rigolo alors oui
je sais pour le coup c'est vraiment pas
un personnage populaire il est un
épisode gamecube à un jeu de plateforme
aventure où il fallait nettoyer la
maison de la famille dans laquelle on
était un jeu sur 3ds où il fallait
prendre des photos de son environnement
qui se matérialisait dans le jeu et est
exposée dans un musée
enfin bref c'est un concept qui respire
le japon équipe et au grand public
bien évidemment mais tout récemment on a
eu droit à chibi robo y plage sur
nintendo 3ds
un jeu de plate forme bien plus
traditionnelle pour le coup qui n'est
pas sans faire penser à des jeux comme
le chien
chibi robo est un personnage que peu de
personnes connaissent et se serait sans
doute l'occasion pour nintendo de donner
un gros coup de boost à cette licence
surtout qu'il y aurait de quoi faire il
peut tirer avec un petit blaster sa
prise électrique peut servir de grappins
dans six plages sur 3ds il peut avoir
une forme de feu et de glace
bref smash bros ferait du bien à chibi
robo et chibi robo fera du bien à smash
bros avec un peu de nouveauté au casting
et pour les personnes qui ne sont
toujours pas convaincus par le potentiel
de chibi robo
je vous conseille d'aller jouer au jeu
flash super smash flash 2 que vous
pouvez trouver sur internet où on peut
l'incarner
et pour être tout à fait honnête je le
trouve vachement convaincant
rayman l'un des héros des jeux de mon
enfance bon dieu ce que j'ai galéré sur
ps1 rayman est un héros créé par ubisoft
et fut grandement apprécié avant
d'arriver dans une longue traversée du
désert
cependant avant cette traversée rehman
avait donné naissance aux lapins crétins
et cet abruti mais marrant qui ont
séduit les fans à l'époque sur ps2 et
lapins crétins font partie de l'univers
de rayman à la base
retenez bien ceux ci ensuite si vous
n'aviez pas remarqué nintendo s'ouvre de
plus en plus aux partenariats avec les
autres éditeurs
c'est pour ça que nous avons pu voir
fifa sur switch ou encore roquettes
ligue et bien évidemment vous en doutiez
un gros projet avec ubisoft fut créé
mario plus les lapins crétins kingdom
battle sur switch mario avec des lapins
crétins et bon sens que le jeu est
agréable et bon les deux univers se
mélangent parfaitement et on pourrait
même suspecté une suite un jour je pense
bref je pense que vous décelez ce que je
vais vous dire mais il se pourrait bien
que rayman apparaît sur switch dans le
prochain smash bros c'est un héros que
personne n'a oublié et qui pourrait
relancer les ventes de ce dernier
surtout via les lapins crétins même
s'ils ont pris leur indépendance depuis
son gameplay ressemblerait semblablement
à celui de spring mancka énoncé la mine
mlt tout en gardant ses spécificités
enfin voilà vraie manette aéro que
j'affectionne beaucoup et nous ne sommes
qu'au début du partenariat nintendo
ubisoft rayman a toutes ses chances et
quel perso penseriez vous voir dans le
prochain smash dites nous en
commentaires j'aimerais maintenant
partager plus en détail la chaîne de mes
amis mais le thé et ue et le studio
poker ou d'
c'est une chaîne sur pokémon mais pas
réellement comme les autres il passe des
heures à produire quelque chose de tout
simplement grandiose mélange de l'esf
les et de youtube poop ça vaut vraiment
le coup et rares sont les chaînes avec
autant de travail et je ne dis pas ça
car ils sont mes amis leurs vidéos sont
réellement travaillé et réfléchi je vous
la conseille grandement
alors allez vous abonner pas ici me
casse pendant des mois j'ai essayé de
fuir ce mystérieux ennemi qui me
poursuit inlassablement où que j'aille
j'ai décidé de me faire passer pour
quelqu'un d'autre mais bon ça vous elle
n'a pas marché est mûr voici aujourd'hui
contre lui en tout cas merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur twitter pour les plus
acharnés d'entre vous cette et argo rock
et que le liner ce soit avec vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]